ma che cazzo hai già bello a tutti
ragazzi è pervenuta che sono video sono
fa vigenti oggi se non su più uniti più
puliti puniti punì ct che è un
videogioco bello proprio bello
praticamente non c'è il menu a caso
perché è partito così siamo su unity che
sarebbe una specie di c'è la torcia che
bello
mi piace questo gioco a sono io con gli
amici cazz.o dei trattori al posto degli
stivali e niente è un gioco horror
ragazzi se non l'aveste capito sono le
11 59 perché c'è scritto qua sopra dato
che sono le 11 59 ragazzi aspettiamo un
attimo che scatti mezzanotte perché non
si può giocare un horror alle 11 59
quindi aspettiamo la vera [ __ ] è
sembra tutto irreale con il riflesso del
pavimento e poi c'è un orologio che non
va a ranco avanti ma [ __ ] o remake
di pt che sarebbe un gioco che è uscito
per tipo playstation network solo che io
non avevo ancora acli 4 quindi non l'ho
giocato questo è mio nonno ve lo
presento che bello queste sono le
pillole non sono né mia né di mio nonno
sono supposte alla madonna quanta rock
the di gente di tutto a posto
stavi scolando la soda e turi lo stronzo
a primo impatto ragazzi la casa è molto
allegra la mettiamo all'asta è una roba
invece sì però dio santo un po di ordine
sta piovendo sta piovendo pure la
madonna in disastro e allora non sono
sempre io con gli stivali niente ogni
tanto mi spavento che ci sono sti rumori
bruttissimi grazie prega ama sei tu
lurida vacca ladra [ __ ] chi è che ti
ha dato il permesso di scivolare fammi
capire dov'è il tuo permesso di cigolio
è la madonna zio fumi in lui non fuma
ragazzi lui accendere sigarette ma non
le finisce le chiavi servono sempre
qualcosa nei giochi horror perché non ne
sta prendendo basta cigolare rotto il
cazzo watch out assai attenta se superi
la porta è una realtà alternativa è la
madonna in casa inter stella io sono io
sei sicuro che tu sei tu sanremo è
sanremo apre sta cazzo di portano che lo
sentiamo la merda singolare tutto il
giorno a preti apriti porta con le
bottiglie apriti bottiglia si vede
proprio quando in casa manca al frigo
porca [ __ ]
devi cigolare ancora pertanto chi doti
rare tra schiaffi fa mica libro subito
però che cazzo buzzi che c'è campanello
cosa bussi è una roba lì russa
tranquillo se c'è il capo puro che c'è
il campanello ti prego non usa è finito
perché era uno stivale di quelli che ci
ai piedi che probabilmente si spacca
una macchina sentita anche i rumori
bruttissimi tutto questo ragazzi sono
ancora le 11 59 però è di qualche arriva
sto rumore bruttissimo sete ubriachi
ragazzi a giudicare dalle bottiglie
potreste esserlo sono fa vj non sono
ubriaco io siete voi imbriaco i bastardi
abbiamo voglia di fare qualcosa
continuavo a fissarle porti sto gioco
niente ho sempre un pene una roba
cliente spento che cazzo ti spegne
giacché cigoli e dai fastidio almeno
funziona cazzo ti spegne come ti
permetti
oh mamma mamma ma mai hai chiuso la
finestra mamma che sono entrati insetti
lì a provare di comprare la zanzariera è
una roba porca [ __ ] che schifo io
che pensavo di essere fortunato di
beccarmi ragni ogni tanto fantastico è
tornato a funzionare solo perché tocca
siate sono col col pene questo quadro mi
fa pensare al paesaggio folkloristico
che ci ritroviamo davanti ogni mattina
nomi sono due merde ragazzi sono due
merda io feci un quadro con le feci non
ha senso nella vita mai così c'è lui che
cigola dà fastidio non rompe un cazzo
pure tu c'è di che cosa non ha pagato la
bolletta poi il problema la smetti vade
retro enel cazzo succede niente sta
andando a [ __ ] la luce fondate no no
dai un'occhiata alla luce che vado a
vedere io tanto ragazzi 12 ore di gioco
siamo ancora qui
non so voi due schiaffi fammi capire non
so se essere più incazzato perché ti sei
spenta o perché sono ancora le 11 59
adesso decido qual è il problema nuovo
di quel ragazzi non ho capito perché si
è spenta
[Musica]
ero io che facevo lo zoom così
tranquilli non è successo niente sono io
che succede da zia il mestolo alla porta
fammi capire cosa è successo perché esce
nel sapere che esce della prossima alla
porta giorno adesso alla fine certo
ovvio ragazzi e cederlo solo alla fine
perché rossodisera cassin nel culo poi è
sparito a caso come diventata nostra la
porta sentite in avanti indietro non lo
faccia questi quasi entrano nel mi
piaceva la pole era bella la porta salve
sono perciò è bella che si ascolta si sa
che in un paio di scarpe quando cioè
voglia c'è il dottor martens senti un
salto da zara lo facciamo i cambisti 2
merda che c'hai belle le mani grandi
come quelle di gianni 6 bel cielo
giungono però il problema o è tornata
nella porta dietro non ci torno che
dietro non ci torno vado avanti tutta la
ste porte di giuro che il primo che le
squadre forti attrae all'uscita da dove
è uscita da casa
che bei capelli che gia e ciao la vj
comunque a piacere so che a casa tua ti
presenti così io uso la stretta di mano
ma va bene c'è un problema
usciamo insieme questo successo puniti
non è finito ma come è finito così a
cazzo ma cosa ma che gioco
cos'è reagan perché crea ed by farhan
cresci cresci kat dyson pt pt ragazzi lo
devo giocare ma poiché è simile a puniti
anzi questo è un remake di pt quindi
appena riesco gioco pure quello che
penso sia un po più lungo perché proprio
no
e durato cinque minuti pulisce mai
konami e la madre devo farlo pt ragazzi
prima o poi lo faccio non mandatemi a
[ __ ] konami nova lo faccio io amico
mio se non crescita con un che ragazzi
questo era più uniti e o punitivo puniti
quello che la morale che se
non avete un frigo in casa ci avete into
culo quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto concluso non mi piace se anche
voi avete delle porte col maestro perché
non so io so se vi è piaciuto al momento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
cani vita tra letizia anche se le
sinistre voci mi davano passo molto
belle ragazze